Halligan everybody it's worn and it's an
amazing day today because Ryan Reynolds
himself has officially confirmed
Deadpool 3 over at Marvel Studios now of
course we're not sure if it's actually
going to be called Deadpool 3 we're not
sure if it's going to be another sequel
after Deadpool 2 or if Marvel and Disney
are going to simply reboot it but keep
Ryan Reynolds
but Ryan Reynolds has officially
confirmed that Deadpool 3 or the next
Deadpool movie is officially in
development and in the works over at
Marvel Studios which of course he calls
the big leagues so there you have it
coming from Ryan Reynolds himself
Deadpool 3 or the next Deadpool movie is
in development at Marvel Studios now
what's really interesting is that it
looks like it's going to remain rated R
this is something that everybody has
been wondering for a pretty long time
now since the Disney Fox deal went down
now that Deadpool is officially part of
Disney and Marvel Studios are they going
to keep Deadpool rated R the fact that
Deadpool is rated R is one of the
reasons that fans truly love his
character and some people think that if
you tone him down and make him pg-13
it's not really going to be the same but
if you examine what Ryan Reynolds has
said it does seem like everything is
going to remain the same he says yeah
we're working on it right now with the
whole team we're over at Marvel Studios
now so it looks like the same team that
he had working on Deadpool before is the
same team that he has now they're all
just over at Marvel Studios now so
although that doesn't confirm that
Deadpool is in fact going to remain
rated R it is a good sign Deadpool in
Deadpool 2 where the two
highest-grossing rated R movies in box
office history each making more than 780
million around the world and let's keep
in mind that Disney is a company and
that's not something you really want to
pass on or mess with and not to mention
there's no reason why Deadpool movies
can't be rated R and then what
he's in the crossover films they can
tone them down to be pg-13 which
according to some recent rumors and
reports that's what their intention is
but no more speculation we have
confirmation from Deadpool Ryan Reynolds
himself that Deadpool 3 or the next
Deadpool movie is in development over at
its home Marvel Studios leave a like on
this video and leave a comment down
below letting me know how excited you
are to finally have Deadpool over at
Marvel Studios and be in the MCU let me
know what Deadpool team-up you are most
excited to see I of course would love to
see Deadpool and spider-man let me know
yours in the comments down below and
don't forget to subscribe and
notifications turned on so you can enter
my giveaway for a chance to win an Xbox
one or a ps4 I'm picking a winner at
five hundred and fifty thousand
subscribers also only four days left in
the Infinity Gauntlet giveaway so be
sure to click the link in the
description and down below as always
thank you all so much for watching
woof woof
you